let me get the super chat here
real quick uh neo tony
super chat says in my late 20s dated
older women 29 to 36 to give them
the benefit of the doubt uh
from my experience unfortunately they
are a bigger headache than women 19 to
29 36 crazier tries to control the frame
and shames to settle
here's what you're going to notice um if
you've got
good frame control as you're as you're
going about your life i mean if this
guy's in his late 20s let's call him
28.29
if you got good frame control you're
gonna have a
far more pleasurable experience dating
younger women than you are
women that have gone past the epiphany
phase oh one of the other things i
wanted to cover which i didn't talk
about i'll get to you in a second mo
just just give me a minute
um the biggest benefit to dating
uh so let's talk about the happiness
of men and women as they age men
generally speaking
are far more happier than women as they
get older especially past about the age
of 40.
you'll find there's a lot of women that
are on ssris antidepressants they've
they've got a box wine you know
subscription every month coming their
way
um they're not overwhelmingly happy
there's things that are not
overwhelmingly going in the right
direction for them
so their so their level of happiness is
always reported to be quite low
compared to men of the same age
especially if guys have it figured out
look if you've been through the divorce
grinder and things didn't go so hot
maybe you lost half the farm to your
ex-wife you know you've got limited
access to your kids
i can see how you may not feel so hot at
that time
but when you adopt a lot of the freedoms
that this red pill lens provides you
when you get into
watching my sort of content a lot of the
books that i've recommended
then you'll start to see things as they
are like you start to see the code in
the matrix
and you find this level of content you
know contentment happiness
i mentioned this in the forward of my
book i was talking about how
some guys actually get angry when they
learn these facts
like how could it be that you know women
are beautiful at 23 and they want
nothing to do with me
at 23. okay but when you learn the fact
then you look at it like okay well i'm
i'm 43 now let's say i'm a high value
guy i've put a dent in the universe i
got a
a quarter million dollar year income
i've got a net worth of three million
dollars i've got some cool [ __ ] that i
can do
all of a sudden you know what you can
look back on it and go cool
now that i understand the way things
work i'll just date a 23 year old
right so you're going to find that if
you can apply this lens to your life
your level of happiness and your
experiences in life in general
will increase they won't go down whereas
with you know for a lot of women it's
the other way around
they just don't have great coping skills
for stuff like that
you